Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number. That number
is 2192. David P. Many comments about my mustache
that I came back from vacation with. Here's one.
Speaker 5: Hi, David. I love this. And the porn
stache that you've got going on the mustache.
Thank you. I've always kind of wondered when
you put on those Teddy Strafford shirts
in the front of your shirt looks so nice.
Creases and wrinkles. Like, you just
have, like, a massive, hairy, beautiful
chest under there. Or is that just the shirt?
Speaker 1: Yeah. No, I. You know, I have thick
Semitic hair all over my body, certainly, But.
But most of the comments about the mustache,
quite negative, actually. Quite negative. My my
girlfriend is worried that I might end up she she
actually thinks I might end up profiled by police.
And I said, no, no, no, no. And she's I don't
drive a white van. But no, the mustache is just
a joke and it will be gone soon. But I appreciate
everybody's concern. We will talk on the bonus
show today about Ron DeSantis setting himself up
to take control of Disney's Orlando district under
a new bill. It's crazy what's happening down there
in Florida. North Carolina senators are sending
a controversial LGBT bill to a vote after a wild
committee hearing, which we will discuss. And
Ted Cruz now says the Grammys the Grammys are
evil after Sam Smith had a Satan themed set and
it really triggered right wingers. All of those
stories and more on today's bonus show. Sign
up at join Pacman dot com to get access to
the bonus show. And remember that tonight
just after 8 p.m. Eastern 5 p.m. Pacific,
I will be live with Joe Biden State of the
union address. I hope to see you there.